[Musica]
e non è stato nei miei sedici anni in
cui il mio realizzato e ogni cosa è la
mia vita aveva a che fare con la
politica
ogni cosa come benissimo cosa leggevo
poi mi relazionato con gli altri cosa
mangiava e lo comprava ovviamente gli
spagnoli hanno un modo di dire che
l'italiano sarebbe il mondo cambia come
un esempio non con la tua opinione
io sono un umanista e le le storie della
storia
ho sempre folto romano ormai lavoro da
quasi dieci anni nel mondo dell'editoria
e della cultura e mi rendo contro ogni
tanto forse spesso si sottovaluta un un
aspetto fondamentale che la
collaborazione quella che secondo me
crea sviluppo intellettuale sociale ed
economico
fondamentalmente l'evoluzione umana con
angelica in realtà che a volerlo abbiamo
creato culturale con la grandissima
spiegazione di creare sviluppo materia
lombaria mente una frase di peppino
impastato elice significasse la bellezza
del gente la si noterebbero l'arma
contro la rassegnazione
la paura è l'onestà perché lui la
bellezza si creano i presupposti per
incontrarsi e per creare ancora bellezza
siamo una libraia grande è la libraia
piccola la libreria grande e fa cose
vede gente organizza eventi e si occupa
di tutto ciò che succede dentro e
attorno alla libreria la mia piccola
nelle fila economiche nelle loro
librerie e disordinata caotica creativa
e ha mai social
abbiamo due librerie una piccola è una
vera la libreria piccola è il risultato
di un processo di collaborazione insieme
a marco il nostro architetto e artigiano
e alessandra nostra grafica grazie alla
loro collaborazione siamo riusciti a
trasformare una botteguccia di 23 metri
quadri in uno scrigno e il restyling
grafico ha permesso di essere
riconoscibile ma è come l'abbiamo
comunicato che ha fatto la differenza
i social sono stati il nostro megafono e
abbiamo raccontato il nostro mondo che è
fatto di parole di incontri a tutte le
persone che venivano in contatto con noi
e giorno dopo giorno abbiamo visto che
gli eventi incontri e aiutare più
partecipati e la libreria diventava
sempre più piccola per le richieste che
ricevevamo e le cosine dopo otto anni e
animata non eran 120 metri quadri in
belle stalli storia voluta fortemente la
donna tirelli nel 1894 diventano a voi
le prime avendole cento la culla della
cultura catanese grazie
al signor romeo prampolini quindi una
tonda che la apre lui longhella riaprono
e s'è deciso di alzare di nuovo la
saracinesca la sempre 19 abbiamo
riaperto la libreria trouble ieri hanno
un sogno di fatto è lavorando solo dopo
tre mesi per cercare in erano un nuovo
di condivisione e li ascolto dell'intera
città
ma volete sapere come è successo tutto
questo qual è stata la scintilla che ha
permesso tutto questo foglio delle
visioni da 15 anni fa mi piace non mi
interessa io nella vita
stavo leggendo serenamente giulio rivano
mi chiamo angelica disegnato per
l'intervista televisiva al figlio di
totò riina
per chi non lo sapesse totò riina
vabbè
e non sarà oggi nel 1992 che hanno
ucciso i giudici falcone e borsellino
creando una censura profondo nell'animo
di siciliani e nella storia della cina
era il 7 aprile del 2016 vedere il
giorno del mio compleanno e quel giorno
io mi sono voluto fare un regalo
appendendo questo foglio che c'è scritto
in questa libreria non si ordina né si
vende il libro di salvatore reina
il messaggio era chiaro la libreria è
un'attività commerciale è fatta di
persone è fatta da due donne che hanno
l'idea precisa di società civile noi
siamo indipendenti e spesso è un po un
problema ma per noi è un vantaggio
perché assurda quella idea di società
civile si sono raccolte lettori e
lettrici associazioni lgbt più
associazione antiracket associazioni
umanitarie è il modo più semplice e sul
vero che nissan e libreria solo in uno
fini lettura
infine sono un veicolo e soprattutto un
momento in cui davvero potete
condividere le vostre missioni e le
mostre
e vedevamo incontro come incontro e
fogli da di social civile era certo
senso in su stampe un pomeriggio nella
libreria piccola incontrai la
responsabile di una grande associazione
umanitaria che mi propose di fare da
luogo d'appoggio per un gruppo di
lettura il cui obiettivo era quello di
fronteggiare la diffusione dell'odio
bene oggi quel gruppo di lettura si
chiama leggiamo per legittima difesa
a due mesi e conta più di 20 iscritti
considera nei saint due mesi faccio
delicato nassi volo a noi e al gruppo di
lettura a testimonianza del fatto che
l'esperienza di comunità e l'esperienza
del nostro hanno un senso profondo sono
soldi ok abbiamo raccontato di gruppi di
lettura di belle parole la comunità la
civiltà eccetera eccetera
però non glielo abbiamo raccontato come
sono non avere nostre librerie
appuntiamo mammi sempre turismo una si
potrebbe tranquillamente chiamare gin
tonic l'altra gmail alle 6 di mattina
gin tonic perché mentre maria carmela
sorseggiava il suo cocktail il vecchio
proprietario della libreria alle
proposte di acquistarla secondo voi che
cosa ha risposto certo
l'email alle 6 del mattino perché lei ha
scritto un'email e ha inviato un'email
alle sedie mattina doveva già
programmato tutto secondo voi io così ha
risposto tu sei mosso
mariam e la sei posta come contrario se
capiterà libri e verdi nella città è
vero stiamo attrezzando per abbiamo i
soldi ma fare con due librerie la
libreria immensa
fammi fare con su un attimo e lei per
rassicurarmi perché fa così angelica non
ti preoccupare catania ha bisogno di uno
spazio sociale uno spazio bello e poi
noi dobbiamo investire sul patrimonio e
sul fattore umano di questa città
stai tranquilla che andrà benissimo e in
quel momento abbiamo detto sì e abbiamo
fatto un passo non solo come donne ma
come imprenditrici e librai e e oggi
finiamo allenatori avrà un pulini perché
nei libri si crea uno dei legami con le
storie che sono racconta dall'interno è
uniscono persone e luoghi e quello che
fanno le nostre librerie è quello di
creare comunità
e se qualcuno un giorno volesse fare
della politica culturale un processo
volto allo sviluppo non deve mai
dimenticare che le relazioni c'è la
risposta è che i libri servono a porsi
delle domande appunto facciamo tra la
domanda ma prima perché le catolino
delegazioni sono storicamente si leggono
libri ci siamo chieste con angelica
che ruolo ha la franzolini in una città
come catania è una relazione a un
atmosfera cittadina che non c'è più un
parente è una relazione con la gioventù
quello è un legame si vocifera
addirittura che è dentro la libreria si
stampasse rowe clandestinamente i
brividi
durante il periodo fascista immaginate
la relazione fra numero trampolini e gli
studenti
immaginate energia
a me c'era la libreria immaginate quante
volte in 125 anni si alza e abbassa la
saracinesca in giappone c'è una
bellissima tradizione quella che fanno
un bacio si rompe anziché buttarlo lo si
ricompone e nelle ferite di si mette
dell'oro e quindi cosa fanno gli danno
dignità ma soprattutto gli danno valore
questo concetto è stato fermo nella
nostra testa quando noi dovevamo rimma
gene are quel pezzo di storia perché non
ci sono una censura come libreria e la
città e lui in quella crepa poniamo
mettermi le loro ovviamente lo facciamo
insieme a tutti voi che sono e vorranno
vivere quello spazio insieme a noi
in otto anni considerate che il tuo
cambiato più volte forma ma non perché
noi due non avessimo un'idea ben precisa
di libreria ma perché tutte le persone
che sono passate che continuano a
passare volontariamente o
involontariamente lasciano la propria
idea e quell'idea poi prende forma
considerate che le librerie sono il
vettore attraverso cui diffondere le
idee di valore e chi la frequenta sa che
la propria idea o ciò che è scritto ciò
che ha fatto può essere amplificata
diffusa ma soprattutto condivisa
abbiamo trascinato in questi anni tutti
e tutte nel nostro mondo fatto di parole
e immagini di poesie abbiamo condiviso
momenti di gioia che loro abbiamo
condiviso insieme la mia palazzina io ho
avuto quest'anno linfoma dal quale
ovviamente solo guarino e lo polli
minori dai clienti lettori e amici e
abbiamo creato
relazioni durature e sincero e questo
permette succede quando dai limitare le
persone e valore alle loro idee e anche
questa politica
[Applauso]
[Musica]